[موسيقى]
انا دايما دايما لما تيجي سيره
الهويه
والاختلاف وارتباطها بالجغرافيا اللي
اسمها السودان
اذكر قصيده لشاعر من الفاز بجائزه نوبل
القصيده بترجمه يمكن تكون مخله وفيها خفه
يعني لكن يقول انه تجري في عروقي دماء
هولنديه ودماء بريطانيه ودماء زنجيه ودماء
هنديه هنديه بمعنى امريكا اللاتينيه
والسكان الاصليين يعني اما انني لا احد او
انني امه يا سلام ايضا السودان اذا
السودان بهذا المعنى هذا هو هذا هو عرفت
ومن هنا تاتي يعني
اسطوره
اول الاساطير المتراكمه حول هو يه هذه
الجغرافيا السياسيه
[موسيقى]
اللغه العربيه
شاعت في بداياتها كانت خليط من اللهجات
واللغات المحليه وهذه كلها لغات افريقيه
يعني انت ممكن تقول عليها
لغات افريقيه بكل سماتها الدلاليه
والصوتيه
والتركيبيه الى اخره
استمر هذا الامر الى ان دخل الاسلام وخلاص
يعني يعني شاعت
سرديه يعني هذا الدين عرفت
وتوغل
وهذا كان عامل تاريخي في انه اللغه
العربيه يعني تتوغل اكثر عرفت وتصير
اللسان وتعلم ما قاله ابن خلدون معروف في
المقدمه يعني انه غلبته اللغه لغالبه
اهلها
وشاء هذا اللسان ولكن ظلت علامات عديده
موجوده يعني الان مالات هذا التواصل فيما
بين الناطقين باللغه العربيه
واللغات الافريقيه
وبالتاكيد المتحدثين بها
[موسيقى]